then we were just like i don't know why
this topic came up with him but we were
like wait what do you think about obama
right and he goes obama
right he goes george bush
thumbs up
we're like why it's like because he got
rid of saddam saddam was terrible you
know
and then so he was like obama wants to
leave he's like you can't leave iraq if
you leave iraq
civil war that's what they said if u.s
leaves iraq
in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to an episode of the
genius brain podcast i am your host
david so i have my co-host ed drake
and ed park
the other ed park
in the house today yes sir
and we're twinning you know what's
[ __ ] funny i just actually heard
about this they actually took it back
but i heard through a bunch of funny
tweets and memes that only fans were
gonna they were gonna block porn
pornographic uh
stuff
why wait on on on twitter on all the
fans
oh yeah yeah i read about it they were
gonna block like no more pornographic
stuff like in the next couple of months
they're just going to take it all out
it's like bread and butter yeah exactly
like we're making millions of dollars
from this all right let's block this out
yeah why would they do that i don't
understand
i think they uh they were saying they
were
having a hard time getting investments
because people see all right that was
the reason that was the reason yeah so
they want to appear more corporate
friendly but it's like bro you have
multi-million dollar revenue stream
already why do you need outside they
want pampers to [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but the worst part of that too is like
there's absolutely no way that only fans
will survive without the pornographic
content for sure because i didn't even
know about only fans until people were
sucking dicks it's like synonymous yeah
it's like synonymous with explicit
content if you hear only fans you're
thinking oh
[Laughter]
yeah you guys you guys are right to make
that move right i'm sorry watch that
[ __ ] happen again i know yeah [ __ ] only
fast
no but with like the whole like you
could tell this [ __ ] podcast is janky
as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah so i guess
obviously these only fan creators are
[ __ ] upset right and i think the
funniest [ __ ] was just everybody just
cracking up it's like now they gotta pay
for that million dollar penthouse what
the [ __ ] they gonna do
all their [ __ ] money because only
fans girls they make a [ __ ] ton they do
man oh my god they make so much like a
bro i i was uh dm'ing with that dm'ing
like that
this girl is a fan this girl's a fan and
you know she's pretty popular on only
fans and i wanted to get her as a
podcast guest but she lives out in
florida
so i was just like hey just on some real
[ __ ] like how much do you make a month
like you don't have to tell me right but
i'm just kind of curious just from like
just i i don't know exactly how what the
revenue stream is right and this girl
has been doing it now for about seven
months seven eight months this girl from
florida
super cute girl
and she originally just started off
doing like uh like nip slips and like
lingerie stuff and then when she started
putting up sex stuff she said her
revenue doubled and just alone on her
like nip slip type of [ __ ] she was
making like 20k to 30k a month
and then when she started doing
pornographic content that's when it was
50 60k a month damn damn crazy dude and
yeah you know when we talk about this
like only fans was the equalizer for a
lot of people who wanted to go in the
sex industry but they wanted to control
in their own space they got tired of
taking getting taken advantage of
getting sexually abused and also stuff
so people who wanted to go in in the sex
world who were like amateur porn stars
who had a relatively big name they were
getting shoots where they were getting
paid like uh like a couple grand a shoot
like yeah and then get like three dicks
up their butt exactly you can't walk
forward like eight hours yeah you can't
work for like a month because you're
sore yeah like two three grand like
whatever and it's like okay you do that
versus you
just being in your room yeah you know
with that
was with the genius brain a neon sign
behind you and then jacking off
and then you get paid literally 30 times
the amount that you were getting paid
before which one are you going to do so
only fans for sex workers anyways became
a way for them to empower themselves
right you take this platform off these
people are like yo what the [ __ ] am i
gonna have to go back to doing what else
i'm doing like what i was doing before
yeah people are going to be upset i mean
if you're worried about losing your ad
base
your main revenue is about to disappear
who the [ __ ] is on only fans for just
regular content
exactly it's again synonymous with
[ __ ] sex so it's like if you take
that away what are they gonna why why
would they stay on that pla somebody
else is gonna come in and fill that void
and they're gonna take all of those
juices away from you watch me eat this
banana yeah
people are going to actually
because that's what happened with tumblr
because tumblr originally was getting
bigger and bigger because people were
putting pornographic content right
like billions ridiculous dude and they
cut that out and now tumblr doesn't even
exist yeah people don't even talk about
it yeah cause nobody's gonna go on
tumblr for your [ __ ] poetry yeah the
hell you're doing your spoken word [ __ ]
like the quickest rise and quickest fall
with like in recent memory of kind of
like a social media platform right yeah
it was it was it was kind of nuts like
because i remember when they talked
about tumblr uh removing pornographic
content i actually didn't know that
tumblr had pornographic content
no like the homies were like bro like
you could find [ __ ] on there that's like
specifically catered to what you want
it's on tumblr and i'm like well thanks
for [ __ ] letting me know
it's gone
but i heard they uh now they took it
back though they're gonna allow
pornographic content to stay on because
i saw that because they secured the
dough
exactly some like a generous billionaire
was like no
yeah i was like i need this investment
that's the craziest thing it's like why
would you do that it doesn't make any
it's not a moral thing of course yeah
well speaking of moral thing right like
when we talk about only fans and how it
like empowered you know both i guess men
and women even though it's predominantly
women who are doing this type of content
to not have to rely on these porn
companies and just they could just take
matters into their own hands right now
from
i guess our viewpoint like society's
viewpoint on this do you think like that
type of thing has been kind of
normalized in the sense of like oh it's
all good like my home girl or my homeboy
does you know they're on only fans and
they openly talk about it or do you
still think there's kind of like that
stigma of like oh you know i don't i
don't really know if i want to be
associated with somebody like that
i think it's it's past that for us and
our generation at least you think so
yeah because i don't think anyone gives
a [ __ ] about what boomers have to think
about it anyway
okay because you know boomers are behind
the scene the ones paying the most on
that [ __ ] sure right right well first of
all i don't understand who the [ __ ] are
the ones that are paying for this type
of [ __ ] so i paid for an only fans oh
you have okay okay just to see oh
research purposes for research purposes
no matter what i [ __ ] you say you're
gonna go there but it wasn't only for
research purposes girl was fine as [ __ ]
so i went to see what what the only fans
was right because you know everybody
says oh i'm one of the top whatever
creators yeah so you see this stuff and
i one of the only fans and it's funny
because my accountant's gonna see this
[ __ ] and i looked at her stuff i was
like okay what is she doing and what is
she getting paid for right
i'm like
it's literally just her just kind of
like whatever playing with herself
finger herself dildos or whatever but if
you want to see the stuff that you want
to see like her sucking a dick or
actually having sex you get like a three
second clip but then you have to pay 25
bucks for the real content this is how
they make their money
with that right which you know it's it's
weird because there's like um
this thing where i know
because a couple of my friends who who
like only fans they say that there's
girls that they've been following on
instagram for the longest time that
would just do sexy stuff that are
finally doing sexual things on only fans
so it's like their fantasy and their
dreams
finally the logical next step you know
if you're already hyper sexualizing
yourself it's
it's a thin line between that and then
going into the next thing let me ask you
something so
you guys are with somebody right none oh
uh you mean right now currently let's
say you're with somebody right oh and
they're on only fans right
they're not yet oh okay right they're
they're fine as [ __ ] but you know on
instagram they were always doing you
know
and then she goes i want to start an
only fans i'm not going to do like
sexual things but i'm going to do like
half nudity stuff
are you guys okay with that yes or no
probably not probably not boomerang
now i'll tell you why i'll tell you why
because
for me i feel like that when we when we
talk about kind of like getting sexual
that's an intimate thing and i would
like to keep that between me and her
yeah
like preferably but then once it kind of
becomes all right it's open to the
public about sharing our sex life like
you know our naked bodies and all of
that
i'm just not with it you know i'm just
not comfortable with it
if if she herself wants to do that
that's all fine and good but then i
probably
can't be in a relationship with you then
yeah if you want to try to now involve
me into that or you're still kind of
doing that or you want to jump into that
while we're in a relationship together
yeah i'd feel a certain way about it man
i'm not going to lie you know is it the
the sanctity of it like it's like hey
that's for
yeah yeah for sure like this dick is for
you
vagina it's for me you know
um it's not like me trying to say oh i
own you or anything like that my sex is
pig
no no it's not like that because it goes
both ways then it's like yeah i'm trying
to keep my
i guess
sexual stuff for our intimacy like when
it's just us too and i would kind of
want the same in return it's just not
special anymore yeah i feel like it's
not special just because like it's
exposed to everybody i feel like that
attitude is starting to disappear though
this idea of kind of keeping things
precious between you and somebody else
and keeping things private because
everything has to [ __ ] be public now
your joy your happiness your sadness
your depression your thoughts your
feelings and it's not even for an
entertainment purpose it's literally
just because i feel that i have to tell
everybody this truth like i have to let
everybody know like my [ __ ] word dude
but maybe not everyone can do only fans
right because maybe you're a girl and
you're like you know what there's a lot
of money out there and you go there and
you post a bunch of pictures and you
make like
you know 50 bucks a month
you know i think you're gonna quit real
quick how about you guys you guys need
to answer the question too
would you guys be okay with it like
this is hypothetical because i haven't
been in this situation right right then
if
i would
i don't know if this is wishful thinking
but then i would think that
you know all these dudes are salivating
over her but i got her
i think that's the way i might feel like
it maybe it makes me feel special
because i am with her and none of you
guys aren't and you're paying for it
yeah you know maybe that maybe that's
the hypothetical thought that i have
okay
for sure yeah yeah i think it comes
along with like having security in that
relationship knowing like yeah all these
dudes want her but they don't got her i
got her though yeah
like that's i see the opposite though
it's like all these dudes want her and
they actually do have her now
like they have everything that you had
mine is actually touching that's for me
that's kind of the intimacy thing is
that like hey i should only be able to
see it's like i'm with her it's like
that's cool i saw her [ __ ]
jacking up exactly there's like there's
nothing that's left to the imagination
and as a result like there's nothing
that like builds me up of like oh
it's like well there's the titties again
yeah like i mean it could be a lie to
myself i'm always saying that i got her
i got her
i can see why why you're whacking it off
this is only for me i mean you got it
it's the same question i would pose a
question to a guy dating a porn star
yeah yeah no i don't know this guy who
has like a 10 inch bigger dick than
yours i mean how do you feel about that
i couldn't do it not to mention like
there is an old school side of me too
it's like if i'm because look right now
in my 30s i'm not necessarily dating to
[ __ ] around it'd be to like get into a
serious relationship hopefully lead to
something more right yeah
how am i gonna introduce her to my
parents you know what i mean there's no
way around that and and like
your kid is going to find that way
exactly that's what i'm talking about
right like your kids in school yeah
that's what it all kind of progresses
your mom's [ __ ] right it's like okay
your parents and then like if we have
kids together and then it's like you
know i'm not i'm not necessarily trying
to um judge the person for doing what
they do but then at the same time it's
like if i can if i know i can avoid yeah
major problems that might come up from
these type of things then why wouldn't i
want to avoid it if it's going to be a
problem for me that i know curveball
what she makes a million dollars a year
on only fans that's what i'm saying
[Laughter]
i mean
it would be the same for me regard i
mean you know i i i was with a wealthy
girl before when we went over this worst
decision
but this guy has integrity
[Laughter]
immediately he already would have
already had a ring in his pocket
done
i probably won't even liked her but she
was so sweet and kind she's very very
nice so nice oh man but yeah the money
part doesn't really matter it's just i
wanna i wanna maintain that what i
consider to be intimacy between us two
and i feel like what ed said too is if
it's kind of all well no no i'm sorry
what you said if it's all out there
then it's just kind of tainted this
podcast is brought to you by candid why
are your teeth the way they are right
now huh did you brush your teeth with
dynamite
you're throwing up gang signs with the
front two teeths huh looks weird huh
plymouth rock mouth listen while poorly
reviewed or insanely priced clear
aligner companies use general dentist
can it only works with orthodontist with
candid the same orthodontist who created
your plan is with you from start to
finish so you never have to wonder how
you're doing your treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist who
is an expert in tooth movement you can
book an appointment at a candid studio
near you or do everything from the
comfort and convenience of your home
kenny can help you get the straighter
brighter smile you've always wanted
right now you can save 75 dollars on
your can of starter kit when you get to
start from home
or you can book an appointment at a
candid studio near you today go to
candidco.com
slash brain and use code brain that's
canadaco.com brain code brain take
advantage of this limited time offer to
save seventy five dollars on your
starter kit candidzio.com
brain code you know you're a good man i
i don't know about that
like you always choose integrity like an
idiot yeah
integrity is like a line that i always
like i don't know man
you don't know
i would never know let's say if the
girl's making 20 million then yeah only
fans nip slips
yeah 20 mil though that's a lot of
[ __ ] money man that's like
generational wealth right now she's
making 20. you said 20 mil a year or a
month a year okay that's still a ton of
[ __ ] money yeah like it makes a
[ __ ] difference yeah i know right all
these three poor men and this is
in this [ __ ] room nah nah yeah i mean
but the question of why subscribe to
like there's so much of it for [ __ ]
free that's what i'm that's why i asked
who pays for this [ __ ] i can it's it's
for the mystique like it's like the
people who do the best that's true it's
the instagram that's true that's right
that's true that's a separation between
like a porn star and just like your next
door you know this it might be somebody
you know and the creators who actually
do really well on it because i had a
girl um
catley shout out to the hunger catley
she doesn't only fans and she makes a
lot of money too she's pretty good on it
she says it's the relationship that you
develop with people on that platform so
like there's interaction yeah they even
have like these these generic
messages that go straight to them it's
like hey baby
it's so glad that you're here my only
fans because i got the one that got sent
to me it's like if you want any personal
stuff just dm me and i could give it
right to you just we'll figure out the
cost later it's like this is generic you
know
this one goes out to david
[Laughter]
this one goes out to davidson
but it's not even the real [ __ ] oh david
yeah oh david
it's like it's kind of sad though man
that people
crave and desire that type of attention
because they can't get it in real life
man and it's like yo
this girl i know is not like being
genuine about it and i'm paying for it
but still it makes me feel like take it
yeah they'll take whatever they can get
even if it costs them money even if it's
not real that's [ __ ] sad and in a
sense it's like a bit of exploitation
there yeah right it's like really
exploiting on people's loneliness and
like their inability to like meet people
or have sexual partners
or they could just be pervs i mean
that's why there's some like women in
the porn industry that i'll see um i
forgot her name but she's young her name
is like
lena lana
lana del something
[ __ ] i forgot it you guys probably know
because i only know of her because she's
getting popular on youtube and they
google it right now
lana del sol if you look she's [ __ ]
pretty dude she looks like a model like
she's ice blue eyes brunette like
[ __ ] pretty as hell and the only
thing i think about you could have done
so much more like
how are you this pretty and you went
straight to porn you know i'm not gonna
lie i've had that thought before too of
like
seeing a porn star that's really
attractive like that's pretty right and
it's not like over like it's not these
crazy triple details whatever
it just looks like an your nice pretty
type of girl and you wonder
how did you get into this line of work
like that's my that's that's a thought
that i have is like how did you get into
this line of work like did something hap
i also think like did something happen
in your life [ __ ] you lana del rey's a
musician my bad guys you said lana del
rey is that what you said yeah that's a
musician [ __ ] what is her name dude
lana pornstar
[Laughter]
lana rhodes i don't know who that is
that would be a terrible i'm gonna try
to find a photo of her where she's not
sucking dick okay well this there's a
big black dick in her ass in this one
let me just show you guys a regular one
of her where she's just in clothes well
there's not much i think the reason why
they get into it pretty much when they
say it's just i just like sex yeah why
can't i
just
yeah that's usually like a pretty common
reason for it um i mean it's almost like
me saying yeah i just like making videos
that's why i got into it there's no
photo of her where she's just staring
straight into a camera with clothes like
if she's enclosed it's because it's her
ass and she's facing this way i'm trying
to show you guys a classy photo of her
well google's algorithm knows why she
searched this
she looks like a supermodel oh yeah
she's gorgeous
do you know what this is
no but she went straight she didn't even
try being like a
regular 20 21 22 years old
wow i said lana del rey she's gonna hear
that i do not do porn i'm a musician but
yes she's a porn star wow but she's she
went into only fans
okay yeah she went into the only fans
platform yeah i did not purchase hers
oh
damn every time you mention only fans
[Laughter]
this is such a weird topic to go into
right after this but
i i don't like doing topics on this
podcast well number one i don't really
think about topics but there are stuff
that's on my mind and if i can't really
elaborate on it it's hard for me to
really form an opinion on it right
so right now i mean there's always like
political warfare going on in this
country but specifically
people like you should speak up about
afghanistan this is what people have
been asking in in the dms or whatever
and
you know some people are getting
progressively upset at me it's like well
this is such an injustice don't you talk
about first of all i'm a [ __ ] comic
all right relax guy like [ __ ] can you
not be funny for like 20 minutes i know
like you're asking me to talk about some
first of all a very very complicated
subject and it's about something that i
really don't know much about i've seen a
lot of stuff right now but it's even
hard for me to process because this has
been an ongoing war that's been
happening for 20 [ __ ] years
yeah a 20-year war and you want me to
somehow be able to speak on this subject
in a concise way in an hour [ __ ]
impossible yeah i have watched
dozens of videos now of people in the
military people in the political space
people who live in afghanistan and
everybody has a different opinion about
what's going on right
and one of the things that i found
really odd and i wonder if people feel
this way too just from an outside
perspective for somebody who hasn't been
looking into this is that i do remember
a rhetoric of people screaming why are
we in afghanistan this is not our war we
need to [ __ ] leave like this was even
like a huge part of people's like
political campaign i think it was that
for the obama administration yeah well
it started with uh george w you know
yeah he's the one who basically took us
into afghanistan yeah right um and
basically since then we've had a
presence there right and the whole well
what what they say officially anyway the
reason why we went in there is all right
so the taliban now their rule is phased
out we're gonna try to bring democracy
into this region and have it be more
civilized right
and
it really was an experiment from the
start even government officials might
have said something to the camera or
like officially on record but then
behind closed doors were like yeah we
don't know what the [ __ ] we're doing
over there everything everything is just
an experiment right now and we're just
seeing it as it goes but for me the
takeaway from all of this is like
okay we shouldn't have been in there in
the first place 20 years later now
you're pulling out the [ __ ] taliban
or or is it the al-qaeda taliban right
yeah taliban is now invaded them over
what 10 days right it took a matter of
10 days so fast yeah took all the tanks
and and weapons and humvees everything
now they're like highly militarized so
they have our equipment yeah exactly
hours like u.s now all of the us
soldiers men and women who have
sacrificed their life their lives for
the sake of duty for country
what was it for
what was it for ultimately then yeah
well i mean
it
it does start much further back like i
think sometime either late 70s or early
80s like the reagan days yeah if you see
afghanistan in the 70s
democracy they're wearing like bell
bottoms they look
alright for real yeah it wasn't always
like this bombed out place they they had
a lot of prosperity you know um
but
russia invaded because like they have
lots of uh what do you call it like
uh miniatures natural resources that's
why we went in there yeah right that's
why we went in there too but yeah
because when when russia went in and
invaded the us
actually sent military funds to the uh
the government at that time or the
rebels at that time the mujahideen or
whatever
and then they evolved into the taliban
so
one of the great victories is pushing
out the russians
but then now these militarized people
they took over the government and put on
these hard strict right islamic rules on
these people
right and then that's when the taliban
took over and just [ __ ] [ __ ] up and
now the taliban are terrible people just
there there's there's no offensive but
yeah about it they're terrible [ __ ]
people
and
you know what though we left them alone
it's like oh that's just what happened
it evolved after we militarized these
people right
and then what happened they
uh they [ __ ] hid what's his name
osama bin laden and that's why we went
into afghanistan to find that
[ __ ] turns out he has he was in
pakistan the whole yeah
you know so now
like
you know when i was in iraq right
similar situation where i was in a taxi
and our our driver spoke a little
english
and then we were just like i don't know
why
this topic came up with him but we were
like wait what do you think about obama
right and he goes obama
right he was george bush
thumbs up
or like why he said cause he got rid of
saddam
saddam was terrible you know
and then so he was like obama wants to
leave
he's like you can't leave iraq
if you leave iraq
civil war that's what they said if
u.s leaves iraq it's going to be bad
sure enough
you know once we were heading out
that that and the [ __ ] power vacuum
happened right isis took over right all
these people were getting killed and
like just terrorism and all this [ __ ]
and he wasn't kidding about that and i
think a lot of the sentiment for afghan
afghani people were if the u.s leaves
we're [ __ ] is the taliban are going to
come in right that's exactly what
happened in 10 days 10 days
all of that got unraveled that quickly
but that's in two weeks that's also
because look the us did try to train
afghan
army they tried they tried to have you
seen that jumping jack video
oh my god you got to see that have you
seen that one no what is that so
like us army is trying to like train the
you know afghani like army or people or
whatever right and they're trying to
have them do jumping jack but they're
they can't coordinate they're clapping
coordination
yeah
it looks like they're doing the ymca
oh my god yeah but not only that i'm
reading like they're straight-up cowards
yeah yeah they know you did bro yeah
even though you put a gun in their hand
you put put them in uniform as soon as
the taliban came in they [ __ ] dropped
their weapons they took off their [ __ ]
and they straight joined the taliban
yeah they're just cowardly people they
folded yeah right off wow
well this is the crazy thing right
because
i started reading a lot of comments from
what other people were saying and
there's some pretty [ __ ] heartless
people in this world because they're
like 20 [ __ ] years of our government
helping you on this is what you do like
this is well it's on you because you
guys couldn't you know get your [ __ ]
together without you know big old
america helping you out well culturally
speaking it's like
okay here's some other [ __ ] right
obviously we can't say names but you
know i'm older now i know a lot of
people who are in the military who have
you know done service over there
and
a buddy of mine
because i wanted to ask him a few
questions before we even talked on this
podcast because he did service over
there and he's like
you can't train some of these people
right just like you said right yeah some
of these people he's not even some he
said all of these people
they're not ready for this [ __ ] yeah he
goes when when because i knew when we
backed out they were going to be [ __ ]
and that is the general consensus and
because i'm hearing this obviously this
is just one person who was in the
military but i've seen other people in
the military talk about this saying like
they're not ready and equipped and there
are there's also other people too who
they're who they're trying to because
they don't like the taliban over there
they [ __ ] hate them yeah they're
they're willing to fight but the people
there's other people that he's enlisted
that they've enlisted in there some of
these people that aren't just regular
civilians some of them he says they're
like [ __ ]
cow town barbarians right like
they have no sense of like human law
whatsoever they're like [ __ ] like
killing people for no [ __ ] reason
that's like 20 30 years of taliban rule
before the u.s invaded 2003 right
because so so many of these dudes our
age too they didn't know anything but
taliban before we continue this podcast
my brain farts we are brought to you by
purple listen i can't tell you how much
i love my purple mattress because well
if i kept it a secret it's not a secret
anymore i've been getting the best sleep
of my life because of my purple mattress
i started loving myself by respecting my
sleep i'm not waking up wondering why my
spine is twisted up like a frito chili
chip guess what no more trials and
tribulations for the back bless yourself
with the purple mattress purple's
technology and their products keeps me
cool supports my back sides hip
necks shoulders and it supports me
emotionally now because i don't cry from
the pain
and guess what free shipping and returns
to what you're waiting for baby purple
is comfort reinvented right now you'll
get 10 off any order of 200 or more go
to purple.com brain10 and use promo code
brain10 that's purple.com slash brain 10
promo code brain 10 for 10 off any order
of 200 or more purple.com slash brain
ted promo code brain 10 terms apply
right and all those like real kind of
quote-unquote soldier warriors were
already in the town taliban yeah exactly
and if you need any perspective on just
how terrible the taliban is watch the
footage of people trying to [ __ ]
fully at the airport there's a reason
why people try to grab onto the wheels
knowing that they're probably going to
die and fall off just to escape the area
that should tell you like how badly
frightening it is
they would rather die trying you know
what the worst [ __ ] about all of this is
it's a sign of the times so the taliban
after they take over oh don't worry guys
we're gonna have women reporters
everything's okay you know because they
care about optics yeah a terrorist
organization that's hilarious about
optics in the media because they want
people to invest into the country
they're talking about like china trying
to appease to them like hey invest in in
the country and we're you know we're
gonna build this great area and hey
women we're going to give them you know
rights somewhat uh heading yeah you know
it's gonna happen like just watching
like i remember i mentioned the podcast
years ago it was like i saw this is
during the time where you know internet
censorship wasn't as crazy and i clicked
on this [ __ ] video and it was a video
of somebody getting beheaded yeah one of
the most [ __ ] that should traumatize
me like i still can picture it in my
head today like it happened yesterday
was it the korean dude it was a it was a
reporter of some sort but he was an
america american person and literally
he's chanting something i don't know
what it is exactly grabs his head he's
screaming yeah and then when he saws his
head he just you hear a gurgle gurgle
yeah and then no more scream because he
cut his vocal cords out yeah and that
[ __ ] traumatized me bro and like that's
kind of their reality yeah and then when
you see these videos in these clips and
once again this is the stuff that i'm
i'm seeing online
of like these women just crying it's
like you left us like you left us we're
we're we're like sex slaves now because
of you like what were we supposed to do
and i think like the conversation of
people saying like it's not my war it's
not my war we already went in there
we're there
like we are [ __ ] there and we there's
no infrastructure for them to kind of
stand on their own two feet and i think
for us to say like
like i get it too because there's also
americans too who have their who had
their family in afghanistan and they've
lost these family members and like this
isn't our country this isn't our war but
i feel like for america because we are
considered like the beacon of hope this
is why we have this rhetoric in this
country of pay respect to people in the
military because of their service this
is why we say this right it's because we
take the position in this world to kind
of write
the evil right right because we had that
type of power and you know and i know
people can say to me well why don't you
[ __ ] go because i'm a comedian
but
i do support our troops yeah right i do
understand their [ __ ] service there's
a reason why when we see military people
where we feel proud of them we look at
our military like yo these guys are
actually doing great deeds not the
[ __ ] but you know people in the
military who are serving who are like
green berets who are navy seals we look
at them with reference because we know
the stuff that they do yeah you know
yeah i mean that's the thing is that
like they just do what they're told to
do you know they don't question like
really the why or the reasoning behind
it even if that's made known to them or
not who knows right
they could be told a lie this is why
we're going in there even if they think
it's a lie it's like well for the
service of country this is what i signed
up for this is what i need to do and
i've seen real life examples of my
friends who've done middle of these
tours yeah back with ptsd right
and it's so shit's [ __ ] real out
there and when i hear about some of the
things that they've seen i'm like holy
[ __ ] man like seeing their friends get
blown up right in front of them bro you
know buddy in my high school
i had to go through extensive [ __ ]
therapy and this was so [ __ ] sad
because i didn't
you know i'm young i don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on right but this dude
went to the military he did he did a
service out in the middle east he came
back
they allowed him to come back and not be
with his his i don't know i don't know
the term military term the crewmates or
whatever right and they were being
deployed to do a mission or whatever he
didn't go and he got replaced because
his his uh grandmother was sick so they
allowed him to come back to the states
and so i think she passed away to go to
the funeral
um while he was gone his whole platoon
died he got [ __ ] blown up
got all [ __ ] blown up holy [ __ ] and
he's like carrying that guilt with him
survivor's guilt survivor's guilt yeah
he was we were we were kicking with him
at a barbecue at his place he just flips
the [ __ ] out starts [ __ ] punching the
wall starts smashing [ __ ] smashing
all the drinks and stuff he starts
bawling uncontrollably and i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on like how can i
be at this barbecue yeah well every all
everyone else is dead i think that's
what it was like he's like sitting here
just wallowing in this guilt because he
you know he
the only reason why he got to go home
was because his grandmother passed away
and then he's sitting here having beers
drinks and food with us and then i think
when he got drunk it just started
sinking in like i get to experience this
but all my friends these are like my bro
they call them brothers you know they're
platoon or whatever i'm not sure the
exact military term all got wiped out
and he has to go back to that
[ __ ] man i i it's no mystery that like
the whole situation is completely [ __ ]
and it was [ __ ] from the beginning um
and now you know they're trying to kind
of politicize this whole thing of oh the
republicans like this is biden's fault
it's like no it's not [ __ ] biden's
fault i mean he's he is taking uh the
flak for it you know but this started
way before biden right and trump was
actually the one who wanted to
accelerate moving the troops out from
that area he's the one that made uh
negotiations with the taliban while
excluding the afghanistan government the
one we built exactly and he made a deal
with the taliban but why right okay so i
mean
we're saying biden just went through
with trump's deal he honored trump's
whatever policy
right but why did we want to get out
during that time too
you know
what i read was that they have a like a
high they're the biggest lithium natural
resource in the world apparently we need
[ __ ] lithium batteries
i don't know why we're getting out of
that but they're also the highest
producers of opium
oh
yeah if you if you look at the timeline
by the time when we got into afghanistan
and when the opium crisis started
that's what happened
yeah
it's like it's not like we went to
afghanistan for the oil went in there
for their opium
and then all these
people died in america from being
overprescribed opiates that's crazy
now that opioid crisis has been dying
down and all this stuff and now it's
like oh we don't need opium we should
get out that's the quote-unquote uh
narrative or conspiracy i don't know
what you want to call it yeah but that's
just one of the thoughts it's just like
now we don't have any need for it yeah
so just kind of toss them is it weird
like there's so much stuff that we don't
know that's going on behind the scenes
that it's hard for me to i mean
obviously i have a very clear opinion
about the taliban like [ __ ] them
terrible terrible people but people also
have to realize too it's like when we
hear this narrative now of like how
could we leave afghanistan you were the
ones who said we should never be there
that was the rhetoric for the past like
i don't know 10 years for me i
constantly remember to hear people say
like this is not our war this is not our
war and then when this disaster happens
they go i can't believe we [ __ ] left
hypocrites like you
also created this [ __ ] narrative and
now that it's happening and you see the
after effects you don't want to take
responsibility for it it's very odd
right it hits a little close to home
because we're korean we're south korean
right no north koreans here right
but
what if the u.s a lot of south koreans
want the u.s military out right but what
if they did leave [ __ ] we're it's
[ __ ] yeah yeah not because korea's got
also a [ __ ] ton of resources and one of
the most strategically
like um it's one of the best like what
do you call it uh geography geography
it's the same thing for hawaii yeah yeah
it's like
it's very good for the us to be in south
korea and
honestly it's done very well for the
country in itself to be honest that's
the hard part thing with the
conversation with hawaii right because
hawaii even though it is considered a
state to me it's not a state of the
united states its own culture has its
own language before you know the u.s got
there the hard part about that anything
for um
a military buddy of mine told me was
like the hard part about that is like
yeah i agree like it's its own culture
and when we put it as a state we're
subjugating them under our rule
but i i love the hawaiian culture i
don't think it's a state but even though
it is but he goes if we leave they're
[ __ ] yeah somebody is going to take
over and they're going to put them under
their rule so who do you want to be
ruled by because it's such an integral
part of where it's located that
everybody wants to be there
they need that i so for us
we're there so it's either us or
somebody else
you know
and that's what he told me yeah that's
why trillions of dollars go into the
[ __ ] military and defense stuff man
because that's how you rule that's how
you [ __ ] you know flex your power and
then wave your dick size to everybody
like hey you can't [ __ ] with us man you
know you can't lie that you the us isn't
an empire it is yeah it is for sure
everything is there was there's a book
about this too where i should have read
it but it was just talking about how
war will always be around because war is
profitable as a business yeah so
absolutely that's why ward's hear all
the time and i think like the hard thing
for me to see too when i was watching
this was i was i was reading um a few
articles about kind of how the taliban
view women and they're kidnapping these
young 12 year old girls to [ __ ] breed
them like they're animals yeah i mean
not only that you know what they do to
boys too right
dude they've got it's like uh
it's like
these hostess dancing boys or whatever
it's a regular thing like
um
uh sexually abusing young boys
apparently is just
rampant amongst the taliban out there
yeah and like okay so
i have a
missionary friend who was in the
military
uh but before he was a missionary he was
he was out there stationed in
afghanistan and he has a story where um
i think it was a raid of some sort or
whatever and they busted in this room
and there was a taliban dude making a
boy suck his dick oh no jesus dude yeah
and so the command leader was like
totally get out leave go hurry leave
right and then he [ __ ] choked the
dude up against the wall right
and he looked at the entire platoon and
he's like this is what we do
shot him the dick
twice shot him in the head killed him
that's crazy holy [ __ ] you know what the
craziest [ __ ] thing about this is too
and um
i forgot who told me this
it doesn't it doesn't really [ __ ]
matter because within their religion
right homosexuality is a sin it's a it's
a death thing yeah but they don't
consider that for boys it's like he's
not a man right so because he's not a
man this isn't gay so that's why they're
having they're having their dick sucked
by little boys and having sex with
gymnastics you're doing into [ __ ]
like what the [ __ ] is this yeah like
it's it's confusing to me that this
exists
right like i i can't wrap my head around
it that's why when some people say they
go well [ __ ] america like i'm gonna
leave this country oh i know i don't
mean [ __ ] here
we're so sorry
what's happening i'm catching them it's
never happened before i am catching the
wrath of the
i'm good for the listeners who can't see
the genius brain logo keeps falling on
ed's head yeah maybe push back more so
it rests on the the chair live or may
angle it or something all right yeah
there we go
jesus dude this happened so often i feel
so bad it was kind of hilarious what the
[ __ ] was i talking about
oh people who like who talk about how
terrible is in this country it's like
you have no idea what it's like
elsewhere like first world problems bro
yeah this is first world problems you
have absolutely no idea what it's like
in other countries man in the world of
the hunger games this world being all
about survival we live in district one
yeah we have it really good yeah dude
did i say this story when when i was oh
my god
let me figure this [ __ ] out
it was a perfect time for an ad break
what was it oh yeah but i don't know who
who exactly um if i ever told the story
before but
there was uh a girl this was in college
in riverside um this is just kind of
like the narcotic situation out in
mexico this is a true [ __ ] story too
this is not hearsay
even though i said
so when i was in college
one of my roommates told me so he used
to go to a church
uh
when he went to this church they were
like mourning over the loss of this of
this young girl right so they went on to
a missionary trip and we're not staying
in the resorts and these missionary
trips i didn't go to this missionary
trip in mexico but
did you go on any uh mexican trips no
plenty yeah right and so we go to
tijuana and it's it's super bad out
there just desolate crazy well this girl
went off somewhere i don't know what
happened but she got caught
by the uh the [ __ ] the mob
the cartel there you go
disappears whatever and this was on the
news you might even be able to find an
article about this but long story short
this girl got caught by the cartel they
asked for a certain amount of money to
get her back right the church can only
raise half the money they said thank you
for what where the money that they got
they [ __ ] cut her body and half and
gave her half back oh my god oh [ __ ]
like this is a true [ __ ] story this
this actually happened so
this is the world that other people live
in so when we talk about this country
and kind of like the [ __ ] this country
i'm gonna go somewhere else where are
you gonna go
yeah like
we do have a lot of first world problems
here yeah we have a lot of real problems
here that we need to solve um
specifically we've seen that with i'm
talking about asian attacks we're
talking about you know uh you know the
black american persecutions we have all
these issues right but when somebody
says i'm leaving this country to go
elsewhere i'm like where are you gonna
go
like i i never talk [ __ ] about this
country i love this [ __ ] country i'm
a [ __ ] american i understand like the
blessings and the privileges that we
have here it's [ __ ] nuts when you
hear the story about like afghanistan i
can't wrap my head around somebody
coming into a place kidnapping my
daughter and turning her into a sex
slave so she can breed more taliban
soldiers i can't imagine that happening
here yeah yeah you know but that's gonna
be anything about it nothing you can't
you can't report it there's nobody who's
gonna help you out there it's a reality
for people out there it's just like yo
your daughter got snatched and that's
that you ain't gonna do [ __ ] about it
and if you do you die your whole
bloodline dies matter of fact not just
you yeah you don't believe like i don't
know if you heard any of the young me
park podcast she's been around recently
yeah maybe even got a lot of surgery
done yeah she made me realize i'd never
had a bad day in my life
for sure it's hard to have that
perspective when your reality is not
that right i mean people don't
understand that life is cheap in a lot
of parts of the world yeah you know what
i mean like it's so dispensable like
i don't like you
boom yeah there was an article that we
did on jk news years ago about these
girls who i think they went to colombia
or argentina right and i think like the
locals told them hey you don't go
outside at night especially if you're a
woman bad things are going to happen
right yeah they're wearing like short
shorts and skirts like whatever like
[ __ ] i'm a woman people need to
respect me to be a woman it's like yeah
in the united states you're damn
straight i didn't have that everywhere
like yes that is what we want and that
is what is right that is not the reality
in that country i think those girls
either got robbed or they got raped or
something it was terrible yeah and you
know just
kind of listening to that i'm like
you you're not in the states like how do
you not
how could you not wrap your head around
that it's like these like that that
white dude who went to vacation in north
korea for some [ __ ] reason yeah and
then yeah he tore he tore down a picture
of kim uh kim jong-un
and they [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of
him until he came back to america brain
dead yeah you know and then he died you
know
like like you said life is so cheap when
when i was in iraq um
we were you know i was telling you how
i'd go to these people's houses for
dinner all the time and it was just so
awesome like whether it was their whole
family or some of their friends would
come in be like 20 people in a room
having dinner or whatever right and we
were supposed to go over like some other
day for dinner
and we're right outside the neighborhood
and the guy who's been inviting us
because he speaks english he's like i
don't go in there yet we're like why
what's going on
my neighbor he
he got an argument and
neighbors shot him in the head
it's like [ __ ] up and i'm like what oh
my god he was like kind of smiling like
he's [ __ ] up isn't it
yes
[ __ ] up yeah we should be [ __ ] up
that is terrible yeah we'll go later
this is why we don't argue over here
we have very friendly conversation i
mean and i met a guy
uh he spoke really great english because
he watched friends
right hilarious he dresses up like
[ __ ] joey or yeah he looks like his
hairstyle the [ __ ] jacket and his
reference of america is your friend
through friends
and then i'm like dude you're like you
speak english so well
like um you know
what are you playing do you have a
girlfriend you know just trying to get
to know him but when i mentioned
girlfriend he was like
yeah i used to have a girl he just went
real selling used to and yeah and what i
basically learned was that i think
because he was
uh having sexual relations or whatever
with this girl
her father beat the [ __ ] out of him and
honor killed his girlfriend just killed
her murdered her wow dude
yeah do you know what i'm saying those
honor killing stuff too by the way it's
kind of crazy because you know like i
said i don't know much about the
religion but they'll have issues like
that even when they immigrate somewhere
else like in like the uk or somewhere
else they'll do honor killings and
there's like these cases of like this
person's daughter's missing and they
found out the father killed her because
you know and he felt super righteous
yeah he goes what's like well i have to
follow the rules in this country so i
have to hide it but i have to honor
killer now because she had premarital
sex yeah yeah so let's make an important
distinction here though too like within
the muslim religion
that's not
right
these are extremists yeah yeah it's it's
yeah
these are crazy people crazy people will
be crazy no matter what it doesn't
matter what color age religion you're
just crazy it's the fanatic religious
people yeah that tend to do this right
because though you know like even within
the christian religion there's people
who take it very [ __ ] history
absolutely lock their [ __ ] kids in a
room yeah you know make sure that they
never see [ __ ] daylight never touch a
boy or girl or anything like that you
see that [ __ ] all the time when we grow
up we grow up [ __ ] up because i grew
up in church too right we were like
learning all this new [ __ ] later into
our 20s because we were so sheltered
from sex
in my 20s
you know but yeah like i mean just
saying all this crazy [ __ ] just to say
look man we live in america
and we're generally like relatively okay
right we're relatively you know
free you know compared to the rest of
the yeah and you know
i've said this where i truly believe
like people we have this concept an idea
of what the american dream is right and
i think like the universal thing when it
comes to like the american dream is that
we have this freedom of choice we get to
choose what we want to be right we get
to choose whether somebody touches us
whether they can have a say over our
body our mind our voice that's that's
what being an american is for sure and i
think that's something that we easily
take for granted because again that's
just our everyday that's a reality right
like for example people in other
countries where human rights is not even
a thing they're not what is this human
rights you speak of you're not looking
at the persecution of other people like
oh that's so wrong it's like oh yeah
they're just weird so that's what
happens to weird people yeah you know
that's they they they get imprisoned or
they die that's just what don't do that
then dude that easy yeah man i i had a
buddy who um
was working as a scout for somebody who
uh did vc [ __ ] venture capital [ __ ] and
he was in uh
tanzania or tanzania
bro like i didn't know this and he as
he's telling me this [ __ ] story i
gotta get him on the podcast to talk
about the [ __ ] but he was telling me
like how they have different rules over
there right like in some of these
villages and like into them as like
their metropolitan uh cities and stuff
he said he witnessed somebody trying to
steal a cell phone
uh and cell phones to people out there
is like a lifeline like that is [ __ ]
important to them it's like their whole
everything and if you have a cell phone
you do everything through that
so it's not like you just get a cell
phone the next thing you can get a new
one so somebody just scooter try to
swipe the cell phone away from somebody
swiped it right well a bunch of the
villagers saw it they just started
grabbing rocks and chucking at this
person on the bike knocks them off off
the scooter or the bike yeah
grabs the person they have like in this
they have a bunch of like a junkyard
with a bunch of tires they stack tires
up around this guy as they beat the [ __ ]
out of him
stacked tires up gasoline let him on
fire wow
while he's inside the
stacked tires in the start in the tires
he said he heard this dude scream as he
died as he burned to death this is why
he was he was in that country that's
correct i got to get him on the podcast
to talk about i know you're talking yeah
friends crazy who got stabbed nine times
yeah in cape town survived oh my god
yeah yeah he told me that that he
witnessed somebody get [ __ ] burned
alive for stealing a [ __ ] cell phone
yeah and that's before the officials
come because there's no officials the
the village is the rule that we are the
law but that's what that's why
[ __ ] here are so soft yeah you
know what i mean they're growing up in
this [ __ ] pampered sheltered
environment thinking oh you know [ __ ]
feel sorry for me because i feel hurt
right now because they won't answer my
my text to them like dude bro yeah
somebody else your age who steals a
candy bar will have their hand chopped
exactly exactly man but again it's hard
for them to have perspective which kind
of blows my mind because it's like we
have this technology now for you to be
up to date with what's going on in the
world but no i'm gonna use it to watch
tick tock videos and try to hit up you
know people on dms like
come on man if you want to be more
educated and use this technology to your
advantage learn about what's going on in
the world so you get more perspective on
how [ __ ] good you have it here man
yeah it's not that bad if you have
clothes on your back if you have food on
the table and a roof over your head
you're doing better than probably like
80 percent of the world yeah you know
what i mean like that's facts right
that's why i suggest everyone will
listen to those young me uh park yeah
yes man you literally just feel like my
life is okay right yeah dude even
listening to francis and gano's story
all right like yeah that's [ __ ] wild
man francis and ghana is so funny
because he's telling this crazy [ __ ] in
the most somber songs
yeah
i don't know
but i had to wake up in the morning
and somebody would make sure i had
dinner but i had no food yeah
like bro what are you talking about just
talking about it like it's so matter of
fact this is sad that they would be in
sand dunes to travel across because he
he had to leave where he was from yeah
and then these women would be holding
their children and they would get so
tired they would just have to toss their
kids oh my god yeah and he's talking in
the most he was like your arms get tired
and you have to let go of the children
what in the [ __ ] world did you live in
yeah that's why like when you watch joe
rogan like his facial reaction when his
friend is kidding he's just kind of like
yo
like the young me park story too like
yeah i remember this one part where she
was talking about
he goes like well what about your family
when you left she's like i can't tell my
family and i'm going to leave because if
i if they know and they have intel
they're going to kill my whole family
yeah and even then if i leave i don't
know if they're going to survive or not
not only are family the next generation
yeah generation bloodline your whole
bloodline is [ __ ] done yeah if you
get caught and they know you know and
then north korea tries to do this job of
like hey everybody everything is so good
here yeah you know they don't have
korean number one man their propaganda
is so hilarious that's why that remember
that show like marielle loved this show
and a lot of people loved the show it
was that show where um it was this
reporter or this like corporate woman
she ends up in north korea
oh lisa ling's sister
no but this is a korean drama oh it's a
drawing
is it korean drama i forgot what it's
called but it was the most popular drama
during pandemic it's on netflix but this
girl ends up in north korea she falls in
love with a north korean soldier that
[ __ ] infuriated me because of how
desolate is over there it's like how are
you going to make a love story about
this [ __ ]
[ __ ] vapid human beings but you know
for other people when they watch it
they're like oh look at that but they're
talking about how bad it is over there
yeah these north korean soldiers who
look like models with makeup on their
face the [ __ ] out of here dude no man
they're stone cold killers yeah exactly
let me you let me tell you how
ridiculous this drama is you know how
she ended in north korea
she was paragliding and a tornado hitter
and she flew into north korea
is is are tornadoes even a thing for the
jungle
yeah i don't think
do you know what would happen in real
life somebody would shoot her ass down
exactly dude if you're a south korean
pig how they would call you you are dead
on site bro you the moment your [ __ ]
footsteps into that territory you are
dead on site when we talk about like
freedoms too this is why people were so
upset about the uh the mandatory coveted
vaccine right because it's
pretty [ __ ] un-american ah don't even
give me you know
i mean let's get started let's get
started this is the thing too it's like
i i 100 believe in the vaccine right
like i got the vaccine immediately yeah
i'm going to get the booster nothing's
really happened to me now it's like fda
you know approved yeah i think like it
becomes problematic when the government
says hey you can't
go into restaurants you can't go into
gyms you can't go into places of
business or anywhere unless you get
vaccinated
this is where it gets dicey right yeah
especially when we talk about americans
and government rule being you're forcing
your hand into people's lives like that
that's when you people are going to feel
a certain way right and even for me as
somebody with the vaccine i can't agree
with that like it's hard for me to agree
with that i get it i understand
but
there's choice here you take away choice
from us that's when it becomes
problematic yeah i mean that's not
something the government necessarily
needs to step and do because i step in
and do because the businesses have been
doing it themselves anyway yeah it's
like you know if they're a private
business they can refuse services for
yeah not wearing a mask or if you're not
vaccinated even right and so
yeah for the for it to become like a
government mandate i
that's a little bit far for sure but if
you're a private business you're free to
have the choice to do it yeah so i don't
understand why they thought that that
would be a good [ __ ] idea i think
they're just trying to prevent
stupid people from killing themselves
right yeah like you don't have to do
that let natural you know you guys call
it natural selection right natural
selection
no dude the hillsong guy who was making
all these jokes about uh kovit and the
vaccine right one all of his tweets were
like he had a tweet where he's like i
got
99 no no he said i got 99 problems but
the facts ain't won and all this [ __ ]
right this is
like prominent hillsong lay dude
um and then he catches covet
right and it gets so bad he's admitted
to uh ironically the corona like the
hospital is called the cro you know
there was a city in corona yeah yeah
it's like a corona hospital or something
oh [ __ ] and then he's tweeting about god
i need your prayers i have faith and
that all these things and then one of
his last tweets are like they're going
up uh what is that put them in a
ventilator but uh where they're gonna
put him in a coma or some [ __ ] i don't
know when i'm going to wake up two days
later he dies
oh yeah really yeah now hillsong people
were sending out their tweets of like
love and like no no so sad but it was
like dog this guy
was making fun of all this [ __ ] you know
yeah and it's like now this guy looks
like a fool your name as an organization
looks even
more foolish and all this stuff like
what did you think was going to happen
now that guy had his [ __ ] freedom of
choice did he not
and it's maybe it's they're trying to
prevent all that dumb [ __ ] from
happening for sure for sure is like you
said
is it the government's responsibility to
prevent stupid people from killing
themselves right it is not
that's why when you see people who were
anti-vaxxers for whatever reason whether
it's political religious personal
reasons and they end up in the icu and
then they get interviewed please guys
this is serious yeah please get
vaccinated i didn't think this was real
and it's like oh now we should [ __ ]
care about like i said you know people
have their opinions about the vaccine
they're like how do you know it's
working blah blah blah blah i'm okay
with them thinking that though i
actually have no ill will towards you at
all you can do whatever the [ __ ] you
want like i'm okay with that i'm just
gonna do what i have to do right if i
take the vaccine because i want to you
know travel more freely i don't want to
get sick and i'm scared that my parents
are going to die
i'm okay with taking the vaccine i have
absolutely no [ __ ] problem but the
funny thing is when i see somebody out
there that's so adamant like [ __ ] the
vaccine i'm not going to take it like
bob what god's going to save me my my
true vaccine is jesus christ
right i've seen that and then and this
guy's now tweeting i need you to pray
for me there's no prayers bro
there's no prayers for you at all
absolutely not you just literally you
have to die on the hill that the hill
that you made that you're standing on
yeah and is that how jesus works if 10
000 people pray for me
i mean look man i think people
need to understand
there's repercussions for the decisions
and the actions you know you do and it's
like well if you don't do that for
whatever reason maybe you even think of
it as a hoax and you don't believe that
this is real and the vaccine is a way
for the government to implement uh
implant the chip in use they could track
you right that's that's one of the
conspiracy theories too
yeah i know right
and then you get kovid
i mean god forbid you [ __ ] die but at
the same time it's like yo man
what else did you expect was gonna
happen here's how you know that
argument's already [ __ ] stupid
because these are tracking devices in
our hands right now
everybody's phone is a tracking device
literally said compost yesterday seven
ads about [ __ ] compost
you're already being tracked your
fingerprints on your facebook it's
already done do that we're gonna get all
these only fan ads now
all right
if you have used google and amazon your
information is everywhere also too who
the [ __ ] do you think you are nobody
gives a [ __ ] about you like why do they
want to track you why are you so special
yeah you know because you're jim bob out
in the midwest i don't want the
government to know i was at walmart last
saturday
i want them to know i'm over here
they already know ridiculous they
already know but yeah i mean look man
it's it's it's hard when you're talking
about like kind of the long arm of the
government and where you should draw the
line um especially with something that
can potentially save lives but at the
same time yeah this country is about
choice it's about freedom of choice and
so when something does actually infringe
on that right
suggesting you wear a mask is not
infringing on your wrist
you know that's it's a suggestion if you
don't want to do it okay but don't be in
the [ __ ] hospital bed on your death
bed being like oh please have sympathy
for me because i didn't wear the mask i
didn't believe it and you're also not
entitled to go get some froyo if they
have a mask policy you know that's a
private business too exactly they can
they have every right to kick you off
yeah it's like the whole no shirt no
service
i will say this though one thing that i
do enjoy about the mask that i will be
doing even if uh
you know we can get out of this
i'm always gonna wear a mask when i'm on
a plane yeah yeah i think i think you
know incorporating mask into life has
become like a lot of asian people do
that and now i know why it's because
when you fall asleep your [ __ ] mouth
is open yeah
like
every time i fell asleep i woke up just
with dry mouth and i'm like oh somebody
had to smell this throughout this whole
flower yeah that air just gets
circulated yeah yeah it's nice just
recirculated not only that i have never
spill smelled someone else's breath for
the past year yeah sure
i know when my brother yeah you're like
oh i
you know it's got
if i'm on a plane and i'm chilling i'm
eating then i won't have it on i guess
like once everybody gets vaccinated or
we get we're in control of this of this
virus but the moment that i start
feeling sleepy mass is going on and i'm
knocking out i don't want nobody
breathing that [ __ ] you know the thing
is too though
that is why we're in the situation that
we're in because of freedom of choice
yeah you know because with that comes
entitlement with that you know
it comes all these crazy ideas of like
what
they can't what they should or shouldn't
do and what their right is and if
something infringes on those rights
that's why like what i think 50 50 odd
percent of the country's fully
vaccinated yeah and we're probably never
gonna make like noticeable uh progress
past that because the other half is like
nah that [ __ ] with my rights and my
beliefs man that's why i think it's
conspiracy that you know i mean we know
now that it came out of a lab
but i think it's a conspiracy to kill
dumb people
to just get rid of dumb better run its
course man we're gonna have to do a
little hurt thinning here you know
possibly quite possibly but if they
survive it they become stronger dead
dumb people
yeah it's true i know somebody who
actually had the vaccine and then caught
covered so yeah yeah but that's the
thing too it's like i i just don't like
misinformation on both sides right yeah
because
you know people hear that and they go
see it's not going to stop you from
getting covered nobody said it would
yeah that's not the point it's so that
you don't [ __ ] die man that's what
dude my uh friend's younger sister she
had a breakthrough case where
she was fully vaccinated she caught
covid and she had really bad symptoms
you know
it's it's happening these days too so
like yeah cove getting the vaccine
doesn't say that you're not gonna get
covet that you're 100 immune to getting
it now it just means
if you do get it chances are your
symptoms are going to be much milder but
there are the breakthrough cases too
that where you can have pretty bad
symptoms and still end up in the
hospital yeah yeah but that's like the
same situation with the flu though right
yeah exactly so exactly i don't i don't
know man like i
i personally think you should get the
vaccine like there's no i mean it's fda
approved now or it's going to be real
soon no fi is yeah pfizer's fights
yes fda approved which is what moderna i
got there
oh i got pfizer you [ __ ] mutants
[ __ ]
well guys that wraps up this episode of
the genius brain podcast a little
heavier on this one except for the first
half
the only fans conversations yeah and
then this [ __ ] tree right here
well you guys can catch ed park at ed
parkvp
you can catch edrick at ed2 and you can
cop your gear at secret society that's
s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y dot
com my friend sir and we will see you
all next time peace